[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they've spent their whole lives in hong
kong
so has felix donna's younger brother
now though all three are unlikely
refugees
they're giving up their friends their
family their home for an uncertain
future
on the other side of the world
it would have been unthinkable two years
ago
the hong kong has been turned upside
down in summer 2019
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets calling for greater democracy
and the preservation of the freedoms
china i promised them the policing tests
we've got tear gas here stay with me
those protests
beijing struck back hard good evening we
start the newshour in hong kong where
the first arrests have been made under
draconian news security laws
laws which britain has condemned as a
flagrant breach of the hong kong
agreement
the scent was crushed and so the uk made
an offer
to the citizens of its former colony we
will grant pianos five years limitedly
to remain
with the right to work or study
welcome to faye's office
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
donna's brother felix is going with them
he had a front row seat to the 2019
protests as a writer for apple daily
an independent newspaper whose owner
jimmy lye has since been arrested under
the national security law
[Music]
him
so when the uk government offered a
lifeline to british national overseas
passport holders
the status granted to anyone who lived
in hong kong before handover
they took it with both hands your
application for the uk visa has been
successful
this means that when you arrive in the
uk
you'll have permission to be in the uk
long as
live to enter and they started packing
up their life
[Music]
they're swapping a tropical megacity for
a very different destination
hey
[Music]
[Music]
foreign day of departure
the boxes have been shipped so they take
what they can carry and say goodbye to
faye's mother who will stay in hong kong
they look around their city one last
time and wonder about a future
they will not be around to see
foreign
[Music]
foreign
heathrow airport
donna and faye have swapped shirt
sleeves for thermal jackets
a little bit exciting and a little bit
worried about the future
actually he cried
when i did phone call some
feel sad yeah yes and our families come
and go to the airport and then we miss
some time
and then really feel sad to leave
their long journey is nearly over
liverpool two weeks later
[Music]
home for now and hope for the future
do you like liverpool yes i love
liverpool faye and donna have enough
savings for two years they estimate
but they're already looking for work i
want to find the job is about
driving because in hong kong uh i'm a
bus driver
and so many around over uh
eight years so i want to find a
driver job in the uk firm
you like a bus so i want to enjoy
driving i feel hong kong is not safe
anymore and
it was not just about safe it was also
about freedom
because we don't have law to protect our
freedom in hong kong
so it was not something we say
maybe a fee harbor anymore
because i believe uk government will try
to protect
people who are coming from hong kong
politically outspoken people like felix
have given up a lot
for an uncertain future and the older
generation know
just how much they owe i want to guess
this challenge
to say thank you to the hong kong young
people
thanks for them because they help us to
get the opportunity we can
immigrate to uk thank you very much